you've heard David Beckham speak it's
like he mouths x2 can of helium you've
heard David Beckham speak it's like he
mouths x2 can of helium I am so sorry so
so sorry
[Music]
tickets for the top
I can't wait to not watch Italy play the
Netherlands I can't stay mad at you
Healing hugs here we go oh god finally
that feels so good
you smell like cinnamon and manhood
we should let go to let go this burden
together just wonderful no okay
would you apologizing for anyway we're
just the bitten Deadpool with the your
voice doesn't ring a bell
what did you think I was apologizing for
I mean there's a list Green Lantern yep
RIPD got selfless terrible blade Trinity
hey everybody it's Charlie a whole bunch
of awesome stuff dropped this morning
starting with Deadpool so let's break it
down if you're brand new to the channel
to be sure to subscribe to get
everything because it's only gonna get
weirder and funnier as we get closer to
Deadpool dropping next week I would be
very surprised if you have no idea who
David Beckham is obviously they're doing
this is a World Cup promo like they did
this Celine Dion thing they have
Eurovision coming up so I'm sure
there'll be plenty more like this the
way they shot this and the way they
edited in that footage from the first
Deadpool movie made me forget whether or
not they actually had that line I had to
go back and watch that part of the dead
poet movies like was this an actual
thing from the movie turns out yes it
was they totally made fun of David
Beckham looks on everything looks are
everything you've heard David Beckham
speak it's like he mouths x2 can of
helium
I think Ryan Reynolds got this far on a
superior acting method so it works
perfectly it helps a lot when Deadpool
makes fun of a lot of these big
celebrities because yeah it's funny but
then usually the celebrities will
respond it gives the movie more
attention so it's always to the benefit
of the franchise that he make fun of his
big celebrities as possible David
Beckham just one of the big sporting
stars in the world I'm so sorry
now David Beckham himself is not a good
actor you may have spotted him during
the Guy Ritchie King Arthur movie that
they did a little while ago movie itself
not so hot but they gave David Beckham a
part where he was standing next to the
stone when Arthur came to pull it out so
that's a lot of sports stars do when
they retire they should start popping up
all over movies and television but you
might not be familiar with all the
movies of Ryan Reynolds if they make fun
of like there are a couple really big
deep cuts like Green Lantern everybody
knows RIPD everyone knew about that
because it was a big studio film every
but he knows about played Trinity that's
probably what I would consider the
classic bad Ryan Reynolds big action
movie tell you two things - I had a lot
of garlic and I just farted he got super
rip from that it was after he blew up
from the Van Wilder movies then he did
blade Trinity then he went on to do more
of the big serious action movies and he
kind of fell into that rom-com hole for
a little while some of which actually
blew up pretty big but it wasn't till
after Green Lantern and Deadpool that he
sort of reignited his career as like V a
list big action star please don't make
the supersuit green or animated best
deep cut that you might not be familiar
with though is when he balks at the idea
that David Beckham calls bolt neck a
terrible movie
bolt neck is like a low-budget
Frankenstein spoof that Ryan Reynolds
did back in 2000 so not as old of a
movie as you would think but this is
after he'd already done a lot of other
stuff but just listen to the plot
summary here a student receives a serial
killers brain in a transplant after
being thrown into a pool with no water
in it amazing premise I know it sounds
like that friends episode where Joey's
fake soap opera character gets the brain
transplant but the brain that he gets is
from Susan Sarandon s character all you
need to hear is that Ryan Reynolds gets
a brain transplant boom sold the other
movie they make fun of that I had not
seen before was selfless
which was actually from 2015 not that
long ago so like right before Deadpool
blew up but the synopsis of that just
reads a dying real estate mogul
transfers his consciousness into a
healthy young body
but soon finds that neither the
procedure nor the company that performed
it or quite what they seem it almost
sounds like a slightly updated idea on
that low-budget boatneck movie that he
did like people being transplanted into
other people's bodies
RIPD definitely a terrible movie Green
Lantern is now a classic in Bryan
Reynolds bad movies I still feel like if
you really want to watch a bad Ryan
Reynolds movie blade Trinity is probably
the best one to go for like that's a fun
bad movie to watch because it's so bad
lantern is just painful to watch at a
certain point the blade franchisee once
it got to this third movie was like okay
this isn't gonna be a great movie but
it's gonna be a lot of fun to watch so
it's a little more self-aware in how
crazy it is but for those of you asking
the blade character Wesley Snipes
totally wants to come back I think if
they bring the character back Wesley
Snipes will be a big part of that but
they might end up recasting a younger
actor and turning Wesley Snipes
into the Whistler of that series what
I'm hoping is is that because Marvel has
the rice that Kevin Feige said that they
have considered bringing blade back but
they haven't done vampires yet in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe so they just
have to figure out how to work that in
because the genre just isn't a big thing
right now but the thing is is that Sony
over in the spider-verse wants to do a
Morbius movie so if that does end up
being a thing like if they actually do
end up making it they announced it but
who knows if it's gonna get made then
maybe Marvel can loan them the Blade
character the way that Sony has a deal
to share the spider-man character with
the Marvel Cinematic Universe for those
of you that are big fans of Marvel
horror films Kevin Feige did say that
they wanted to do a horror film at some
point that's basically where the blade
character would fit so even if they
don't share them with Sony or they don't
do any kind of crossover with Morbius or
anything like that they will still
eventually get to the point where they
can do a legit horror film and I feel
like the Doctor Strange character is
really good for that too so we'll see
how this all works out in phase 4 and
phase 5 but there was so much awesome
stuff that dropped this morning I'm
trying to work through all the videos if
you guys didn't know Rick and Morty was
confirmed for season 4 but that's not it
they actually renewed rick and morty for
70 episodes which is basically five more
seasons with fourteen episodes each
because dan harmon a long time ago
talked about doing more episodes per
season if you don't know what Rick and
Morty is and you're not a big fan of
that show don't worry I'm gonna do a
separate video about that but all that
news dropped while I was making this
Deadpool video and I just got super
excited I will also be posting new
infinity war really soon too so click
here for brand new infinity war and
click here for that other Deadpool
spider-man trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]
you